like I didn't think that it was gonna
blow up the way it did and I've run so
many like messages from people that I
don't even know like that are like
saying that they would like die for me
[Laughter]
there's so many like really kind people
out there that really just want to see
us doing good yeah it just feels really
amazing I mean you guys have touched so
many people's hearts and lives I'm
curious how you guys feel about how you
were each portrayed on the show like do
you think it was accurate was it strange
to watch yourselves back it was it was
accurate for the most part I think
towards the end they kind of like
painted me out to look like I was
messing it up really badly and I did
like put on Twitter that the rave scene
that they put in the last episode
actually happened months before Daytona
and they made it look like that's all I
was doing when I left and it's not the
case and they kind of just made it seem
like when I left that I was just gonna
be screwing up and everything and I
actually went to school just not to
Navarro and that's the only thing that I
think wasn't really accurate but
everything else like they did a really
amazing job of like telling that story
yeah even though I'm not necessarily an
avowed cheerleader anymore I still feel
like I'm a reflection of that program
did that frustrate you at all pick a
little bit because I made Raving and
like that whole like community like look
kind of like a negative thing like it
was like it was bad and about making bad
decisions it's not about making bad
decisions it's about being in an
atmosphere like listening to good music
enjoying yourself then I just like
wanted to clarify the like it's not
about like I mean the negative it's not
about making bad decisions and that's
really the only thing that I think
wasn't really like super accurate yeah I
was dreaming the whole time I was she
just said she had gotten in trouble and
that she can't be a cheerleader there
and
you did leave Navarro now you are back
what conversations did you have with
Monica to get back onto the team
well basically whenever I was going to
the other college I just didn't feel
like it was a good fit for me I wasn't
really like I didn't have that at home
feeling that I did whenever there I was
at Navarro and I like told my parents
and like a few people about it and they
had like reached out to her and actually
the whole time I was at the other school
there was like a bunch of people on
Navarro saying please come back and even
the assistant coaches Andy and I were
communicating I was still communicating
with Monica - it just wasn't about
coming back until like it was I found
out like it was really working out for
me and Monica's been like the type to in
the past she's given second chances and
she she like knew that like my
intentions like weren't bad and that I
did really want to like you know prove
myself that I like and I'm not like the
bad decisions that I've made I'm better
than that
so she was open to like giving me
another chance and I'm really thankful
she did because life's been so crazy and
like just crazy in a good way since I've
been back yeah so you stopped tumbling
for a little bit it seemed like it's
been like I stopped tumbling in October
so that's about like four months that I
just wasn't tumbling why did you stop I
was cheering at the other school I went
to and I quit the cheer team because I
just didn't really like I didn't I
wasn't feeling it I didn't feel like it
was a good fit for me and so after I
quit the cheer team all I was just doing
was going to class and I was just
focusing on school and that's really all
I did was just that and I just didn't
really have like the motivation to like
go into the gym and tumble did watching
the documentary inspire you to get back
into cheer definitely I think that's one
of like the major reasons why I wanted
to come back was just like watching it
like put me on such an emotional
roller coaster because last year really
was an incredible year but like getting
to rewatch it and relive that like it
made me want to like come back and
experience all of that all over again
because it's like an undescribable
amazing feeling yeah with the second
chances are there different rules that
you have to adhere so it always depends
on like the situation cuz like
everyone's situation is different
there's people that she never let come
back and then there's been some cases
we're like okay talk it out like I know
that your intentions are good yeah I'll
give you a second chance it really just
depends on your situation and what
Monica like actually she's good at
reading people like she can tell if
you're actually serious or if you're not
mm-hmm and she could tell that I really
wanted it would you say to her to
convince her that you had good
intentions well I really didn't have to
say much because like the last time that
we had spoken before I left like we were
both crying like we died we both didn't
went like that out coming to happen and
like she knew that I was like before I
even left Navarre like she knew that I
was like disappointed and myself and
like would have never like done anything
like that you know to ruin my chances of
having a good career you're doing good
now of course
[Music]